so Florida Governor Ron de Santos urging
Spring Breakers to comply with the CDC's
recommendations to keep gatherings under
10 people but Democrats in the state say
it's not enough demanding tonight that
he quote immediately close all access to
the public beaches correspondent Phil
Keating live in Clearwater Beach which
has been pretty crowded this week he's
there tonight hi pal hi Martha and
breaking down south in Miami this
evening the city of Miami mayor who
tested positive for Cove in 19 or this
week said from his sequestered house and
urging of all city of Miami residents to
shelter in place voluntarily that is
nearly 3 million people all week long
Clearwater Beach has been the subject of
national scolding and shaming for all
the families and Spring Breakers
crowding on the beach basically ignoring
the CDC's social distancing standards
perfect timing for this live shot as you
see it is sunset right here in the Gulf
Coast capping a gorgeous day on the
beach another day on the beach with a
whole lot of people now we saw people
all gathered together but they were
seeming to finally get the message about
keeping apart and taking it seriously
everywhere we looked it was always a
proper amount of space and distance
between beachgoers as it's supposed to
be statewide most of the beaches do
remain open although more are closing
each day but everyone is supposed to be
spaced out groups smaller than 10 and 6
feet apart but here's what Clearwater
Beach look like on Monday despite the
pandemic threat so at an emergency
meeting called last night clear waters
Council reacted to the criticism ruling
all beaches will be closed starting
Monday but that changed this afternoon
as Pinellas County closed all beaches
for weeks and that begins at midnight
over in Cocoa Beach on the Space Coast
more Spring Break crowds packed a beach
Wednesday with little concern about a
virus many young people apparently think
only seriously affects the older
generation family vacation everybody's
freaking out over this karana virus
it's a cold wash your hands plain and
simple my wife's a nurse so it doesn't
really affect us as long as we maintain
what we're supposed to do and
Millennials with immortality delusions
should note this the CDC reports that of
all people between the ages of 20 and 44
who come down with Kovan 19 20% ended up
in the hospital and the CDC also
reporting that nearly 40% of all the
people who who test positive for
coronavirus they're all under the age of
55 several members of Florida's
delegation now urging the governor to
close all the beaches for good right now
it's just a beach town decision whether
or not to shut the beach Martha all
right good good facts and that new study
that shows that it clearly does impact
people who are younger in that age you
know 20 to 50 age group as well Phil
thank you very much folks in Clearwater
Florida tonight